I'm gen Brian, and I'm the host of the Congressional dish podcast
And I'm filling in today for David because he's on his way to Sin City
And he's going to be reporting to you from Vegas for the rest of the week
but today I've been telling you the story of the
Omnibus funding law and how it became law and there's one last piece of the how the omnibus became lost story
that just made me aware of something that I didn't know before and you probably didn't know either because
Who tells us these things and so?
To get a bit wonky for a second the way the omnibus was able to move faster
Through the process is that it was basically
Attached to a bill that had already passed both the House and the Senate the bill was numbered HR
1625 and so if you look up the the omnibus now it says that this HR 1625
But it wasn't always it used to be a completely different bill and so the original text was
One that actually did become law as a part of an the omnibus
So I figured I might as well tell you about it the original text was called the target Act
Which stands for targeted rewards for the global eradication of human trafficking and?
The changes that it makes to the law is there actually no big deal
but it's what it changes the program that already exists that I
Found out about reading this and just went like what the hell so what the target Act does is?
It adds human trafficking to the definition of transnational
Organized crime in order to allow the State Department to pay people who give information to the State Department
information that leads to arrests of criminals and
So essentially what it does is it allows money to be paid to stitches
And I didn't know that the State Department had a program for paying snitches apparently it does and so this bill just adds
one more thing that people can snitch about
Now this cash first snitches program allows the State Department to appropriate quote such amounts as may be necessary
Unquote which is kind of unusual I mean, I read these bills a lot
And it's kind of unusual for an agency to determine its own funding levels
It's generally what Congress is four and then these payments
I looked up the caps so I was like how much are we paying these people?
well
They're capped at 25 million dollars except us personally authorized by the Secretary of State which as of right now is
No one
But for the last year or so it's been Rex Tillerson the the former president and CEO of Exxon Mobil
So god only knows who he was paying so yeah twenty five million dollars is the cap but?
The cap is actually 50 million dollars for information leading to the capture of a leader of a foreign terrorist
Organization 50 million dollars, and then another thing I found kind of fascinating is that payments under
$100,000 don't need approval at all from the Secretary of State and
I one last thing that I found disturbing is that these decisions made by the Secretary of State are
Final and are not allowed to be reviewed by the courts, so this is a disturbing program
And it wasn't always like this because I looked up the original law the original law was created in
1984 which kind of ironic
ID maybe for if you've read that book
But the original law was written in 1984 and it allowed payments to be capped at half a million dollars
So we've gone from half a million dollars to fifty million
Dollars in payments first snitches and then all the payments back then needed approval
But payments over a hundred thousand dollars had to be approved by the President himself
So now the same number a hundred thousand dollars or more has to be approved by the Secretary of State who again is no one
And it used to be that the President himself had to be
Approving these so this is this is just a much bigger program than was ever
Intended and I think it just goes to show how far off the rails Congress has gone since the beginning of the war on terror
Today's program is sponsored in part by shaker and spoon a monthly cocktail
Subscription box delivering the full craft cocktail experience right to your door they send you the ingredients
for three
Completely new and original craft cocktail recipes enough for 12 cocktails should be enough to get you through the whole month
I got the death by gin box meaning. I got the ingredients for three
forant gin-based
Cocktails and I'm able to go and choose the brand of spirit that I want I happen to go with a particularly
Dry gin in addition to sending really clear
recipe cards for each recipe in the box you can also watch the
Supplemental how-to videos by shaker and spoon which is useful sometimes I admit. I don't exactly know the difference between
Shaken stirred and who knows what other options there? Are I'm generally clueless so for me
I need the Supplemental how-to videos and for a limited time our audience can get
$20 off by going to shaker and spoon comm slash Pakman if you're watching this on YouTube
I've put a link in the description underneath this video, and you can check out the how-to videos on YouTube as well